philippe passez moi les grandes vitesses
on a 20 ans du courage on ne se plaint
pas cependant ce travail qui détournent
des études est il vraiment favorable aux
examens philippe est assistant dentiste
mais en vérité que fait-il je suis
étudiant en lettres les étudiants
allaient les jours alors eh bien parce
que je pense que enfin j'ai 20 ans alors
il est normal que je travaille pour
payer les mêmes les objets dont j'ai
besoin c'est à dire que vous venez ici
combien de temps je viens tous les
matins sauf le vendredi c'est à dire
cinq matinées par semaine dès telle
qu'elle est de 8h30 à 12h 12h30 et
l'après midi dans l'après midi je vais
au cours à la sorbonne
vous allez suivre au cours de l'être
mais je suis mes cours de la nuit mais
est ce que ce travail ne nuit pas trop à
vos équipes de 6 sa nuit un peu parce
qu'évidemment il ya deux matinées par
semaine par exemple où j'ai des goûts je
ne peux pas y aller alors je manque
c'est court je peux me les faire passer
par un camarade m'enfin je vais manque
et pour votre travail vous devez vous
lever très tôt arrivé à 6h30
puisque j'habite assez loin il faut
venir et combien gagnez-vous par mois je
gagne 1000 francs par jour ça fait vingt
mille francs par mois mais comment les
utiliser ou bien je paye mes transports
d'abord tous les livres dont j'ai besoin
à faculté puisque j'ai envie de dire de
mal de payer mes repas parce que je suis
chez mes parents mes jeunes en jeu mais
par le matin et le soir à midi et puis
tout le reste l'argent de poche ont
pensé que quand on fait des études on
doit obligatoirement travail est
obligatoirement non mais je pense que
c'est nécessaire et il serait bon que
les études souvent des absorbants pour
qu'un jeune homme puisse s'intéresser à
beaucoup d'autres choses que ces études
est elle-même quoi
le